as well a lot of time here 2.1 seconds
remaining denver foul to give jokic
trying to disrupt rondo he puts it in
here's davis 4-3 in the win
oh it's gone anthony davis has won
it for the lakers
[Applause]
anthony davis
scored as a good three-point basket they
will take a look but anthony davis
is going to send the lakers to a 2-0
series lead
in the clutch delivers the bomb
great defense by the nuggets just
outstanding
offense by anthony davis
who's made back to back huge threes here
in this fourth quarter
they confirm the basket game over great
play call by coach vogel what he did was
he put the screen on the big fella big
fellas aren't used to coming off the
screen
playing defense that's why yokis did a
great job getting the hand up but that
was plumley's man coming off the screen
anthony davis scores the last 10 laker
points chris
and that's what i'm talking about that
screen lebron the best decoy in the
world right there the switch bringing
plumley up
we've been giving coaches credit all
night the trust of coach michael malone
but how about vogel
trusting the big fella the